We've all been there.
You take a photo and you see the subject's in focus...
...but the background, the whites are washed out...
...and the darker areas are just one huge blob of darkness.
This is where HDR mode comes in handy.
But what exactly is HDR?
Let's find out, shall we?
HDR  or high dynamic range makes your lights lighter...
...and your darks darker, in a good way.
Usually how that happens is, photos are taken at different exposures...
...from the very dark to very light...
...and then they're merged into one beautiful HDR image.
HDR technology is also used in video.
In fact, Hollywood studios use HDR when shooting...
...and mastering the footage.
And to view the contents as intended by the creators,...
...HDR-compatible TVs became somewhat of a necessity.
From the birds in the clouds on a sunny day...
...to little creatures hidden in the darkness,...
...that's what HDR 1000 is all about.
See the world as it should be seen.
This is TV.
Samsung SUHD TV.